good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight during a roundtable with elected
officials and law enforcement yesterday
President Trump took a question about
the gang ms-13 as he has before the
president expressed his thoughts in the
subject bluntly we're taking people out
of the country you wouldn't believe how
bad these people these are people these
are animals well if anything that's a
mild description dogs are animals that a
lot of them sleep on the bed you
wouldn't want to be anywhere near ms-13
they trafficking drugs weapons and human
beings young girls unlike animals they
kill for fun often with machetes they
terrorized the poor and the vulnerable
they've met El Salvador the most
dangerous country in the world there's
literally no defending them and yet the
left is defending them here's to the New
York Times described what the president
said quote Trump lashed out at
undocumented immigrants during a White
House meeting calling those trying to
breach the country's borders animals
over at Jeff Bezos is vanity publication
The Washington Post there was this quote
Trump evokes an ugly history of
dehumanization so the president is a
Nazi for criticizing a violent street
gang newspapers haven't been this yellow
since they started the spanish-american
war for her part over at the house
Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi raced to
the nearest microphone to defend the
dignity of ms-13 watch this we're all
God's children there's a spark of
divinity in every person on earth and so
when the President of the United States
says about undocumented immigrants these
aren't people these are animals you have
to wonder it does he not believe in the
spark of divinity the dignity and worth
of every person every day that you think
you've seen it all along comes another
manifestation of why their policies are
so inhumane well that's not just
dishonest though obviously it is it's
lunatic why would the Left be defending
the country's most violent street gang
Trump has made them irrational that's
part of it but the left also sends as a
threat to its most basic worldview ms-13
is a living reminder that the left's
position on immigration is fundamentally
a lie the media tell you every day that
every immigrant legal or not is a future
brain surgeon or tech company founder
therefore immigration controls are
unnecessary if they admit that ms-13 is
actually bad it must be stopped they'd
have to also admit that when some
countries send their people here they
aren't sending their best a lot of
immigrants are great for sure some of
them are rapists though some join ms-13
that's just true they're not all the
same because people aren't all the same
that's the point of our immigration law
they're not the same we should sort the
good from the bad but that's too much
for the left it suggests that this might
be a real country whose actual citizens
have interests that are worth protecting
yesterday on Twitter the governor of
California Jerry Brown went after the
president's views on immigration and he
ended his tweet this way quote we the
citizens of the fifth largest economy in
the world are not impressed
citizens of the economy that says it all
to the modern left you're not an
American with a culture and a history
and a collective identity you're a
citizen of the economy a cog of the
Machine of global capitalism to Jerry
Brown and Nancy Pelosi and their many
donors America is just another private
equity scheme their pledge is different
from yours and to the economy for which
it stands one economy indivisible with
open borders and low wages for all
that's the future they promised don't
worry it'll sound better in Spanish